dernière fois qu'on lui a parlé c'était
lors de la diffusion du documentaire la
terre vue du coeur un magnifique
documentaire sur les défis des humains
face à notre planète est ce qu'il
n'était pas trop tard oui non mais
hubert reeves était plutôt optimiser
centration aussi mais peut pas dire
qu'il est trop tard mais on est à 23h59
d'une extinction etc
hubert reeves est à paris bonjour
monsieur rives bonjour mr yves est ce qu
on aurait pu imaginer qu'une si petite
bébête puissent paralyser l'ensemble
mettre ko l'ensemble de l'économie
mondiale
ou si l'on tarde en fait on le savait
mais on avait à publier c'est l'exemple
de la peste noire qui a vu autour de 14
on a tendance à ignorer ces menaces
on sent pense que nous sommes là fragile
sur beaucoup de plans et ça ça nous a
rappelé l affaire c'est paradoxal le
monde attendait des événements
dramatiques la seule à se loger tout le
monde parlait de l'économie c'est ça et
puis nous analysait cette nouvelle de ce
poison à virus
iliad un domaine que personne je pense
en tout cas je n'ai pas beaucoup de gens
qui ont ainsi compensé et à cette
possibilité d'inclure cette possibilité
c'est étonnant c'est à dire ce qu'on
pense que cette affaire l'avait oubliée
en procès en 2009 décidemment bien et ça
nous rappelle cela et il a donc souhaité
récente à dire c'est que on n'arrive pas
sur certains essaient de montrer ses
thèmes liés à l'écologie aux problèmes
économiques
si l'on avait trouvé beau qu'il se
battait cette version mais ça nous a
rappelé qu' on a facilement tendance en
appui sur le jour d'une même chose dans
sa simple c'est très bien pour
l'humanité ils savent de se préparer ça
se recueillir et ça va probablement
devenir on nous annonce que le fait
qu'on l'a eue te motive et occasionner
c'est un service est plus sûr on
entrevoyait je suis allé à 7 ans chassé
à l'échelle de la planète
c'est quelque chose que personne
n'attendait et puis on l'a injustement à
tirer les leçons
ça veut dire qu'il y aura un avant et un
après est-ce que si être utopique de
croire que ça va nous servir justement
de leçon pour acheter localement
davantage pour démondialiser quelque peu
notre planète pour respecter davantage
notre environnement pour moins
carbonisés notre atmosphère est ce que
est ce que c'est utopique croire ça où
il ya une possibilité réelle que ça le
choc aura été bénéfique
j'espère c'est qu'on espère qu'on va pas
après coup retrouvé nos mauvaises
habitudes je connais pas la vie que ce
soit un choc qui bénéficie à l'humanité
c'est aussi possible malheureusement cet
entrepôt le cas que ce soit simplement
une grosse alerte et puis quand on soit
revenu à la vie normale c'est à dire que
ces virus vont cesser de se multiplier
de façon mécanique c'est le choix dans
le souhaite on peut faire et qu'on en
retire
captain planet 2 laisse faire n'importe
quoi comme je vous dis l'avenir est
inconnue comme on avait jamais assez de
ne pas obtenir des choses comme ça il
est parfaitement en étant incapable de
dire comment sera la vie dans un an on a
des cas c'est quelque chose de majeur
pour toute l'humanité dans un mois ou
dans un an
personne ne peut dire comment t'es tu ne
marcheras l'état du maine
la leçon à prendre
c'était nous sommes fragiles et et nous
avons l'exemple là de notre habilité
il ne touche en plein fouet est ce que
vous êtes par ailleurs inquiet de la
dune niveau les ans les pays ne sont pas
armés de la même façon pour faire face à
cette crise sociale tous ces pays du sud
il ya l'afrique il ya l'inde etc
est ce que bon nous qu'un en europe en
amérique du nord les choses iront peut
mieux est ce que on ne risque pas
d'oublier
des coins où s'en va être encore très
difficile oui j'espère trouver d'oubli
repas en fait je trouve qu'il ya quand
même la réaction
il ya beaucoup de grandeur d'âme il ya
aussi beaucoup de machinerie va le
président de pays possible de chez vous
la montrer hostile à dieu je ne veux pas
je vais acheter débats c'est pas des
bascules qui vont s'étendre en europe
je veux que ça garder pour nous c'est
l'exemple même de la mesquinerie du
chacun pour soi
heureusement il ya d'autres endroits il
ya des actes héroïques dont total boucle
à la télévision commence l humanité l
université de tours dans l'humanité
effet quand on a décrit comme ça des
moments aussi et fit illusion si on peut
voir un peu elles sont ce qu'ils avaient
à dire de façon à mettre lui-même vers
leurs plus belles voix et sa rivale à sa
rivale le bien mais arrivait le mal
aussi
j'ai les jambes mais quand même
monsieur legault qui dit jeudi dernier
on devra davantage cultivés dans des
serres des fruits des légumes au québec
pour être davantage au tout de suite
suffisant donc de ça veut dire moins de
camions en principe sur les routes
là ça va être le côté optimiste qui
parle moins deux camionnettes - ça va
être de faire ce que des écologistes me
disent depuis des années produisit
localement il ya quelque chose de bien
on peut espérer un coup une puissance
nouvelles ont la possibilité
la plupart l'écoutent les gouvernements
sont plus enclins à améliorer leur
comportement qui prend des positions de
chacun vous avez tellement raison là
dessus mais c'est bon de réfléchir à la
paix
mais comme vous disiez je sentais
l'inquiétude dans votre voix rien ne dit
que quand on repartira la machine
parlons pension à la chine ou à d'autres
pays on va pas au contraire la repartir
encore plus vite possible tout est
possible c'est en tête c'est un examen
de passage
vanité maintenant affronter un problème
il revient vers des débits sans déni des
épidémies il y en a eu beaucoup dans le
passé on n'attendait pas de nos jours
c'est généralement on a ciblé disent ils
pour les empêcher de prendre des
dimensions cyclables
c'est la première fois depuis longtemps
qu'on n'a pas eu une épidémie à
l'échelle mondiale c'était la fondation
et puis en série comme vous dites on
peut espérer qu'on va se préparer
pendant la limace qui postulent ça la
phrase de la france est assez lamentable
il avait 18 il ya quelques années la
provision de masques à d'abord battu
deux fois et si il se trouve obligé dans
la chine aura trier toutes les leçons
pour apprendre
on va se rappeler se souvenir que c'est
possible que c'est toujours possible si
on vous avait raconté il ya six mois
qu'on allait avoir ce genre d'événements
du genre dit pas non non c'est un tollé
à venir des mollahs le gars a fait tout
ça non ça n'a pas été mon tour et se
faire contrôler à l'échelle de la
planète plus mauvais le plan avant de
vous laisser un rêve comment vous vous
vivez le confinement
de rester chez soi et c'est vous on
s'imagine lire et pas seulement écrire
un nouveau bouquin que je pouvais pas
avec les arrivées pas la preuve dans
heavy rain je ne suis pas du tout fâché
on est dans un appartement confortable
on peux pas te dire mais moi ça me
dérange pas tellement hubert reeves
astrophysicien penseurs merci beaucoup
de nous avons parlé de paris merci à la
prochaine